alors tu le sais je suis un énorme fan
des planètes et j'ai même réalisé une
chorégraphie dessus qui je pense qu'on
peut le dire mais vu sa venue c'est
devenu la danse officielle et j
officials si charlize nous regardons
qu'à regarder ta peau contre mam
[Musique]
ap
est ce que propose free mobile
[Musique]
j'ai lancé
j'ai lancé le mpi planait challenge bah
ouais alors il ya plein de fans vous et
des chroniqueurs qui aussi tenter le
challenge regarde il ya du bon et du
moins bon
y a pas que du bon isabelle a là rien
compris à l'accord y regarder quand je
danse
prudent
les planètes
est
invités
[Musique]
bien
du jour
tap au contraire ma
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
m
contre ma
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
paul s
et à la version d'isabelle l'élève
cassage de bras au 4ème excusez moi vous
vous étiez où vous en faites chez moi
adacore battu genre d'appareil à mon
avis est ce qu'elle n'aurait pas pris
les trois millions de gens voyons c'est
ça je pose la question est ce qui serait
pas dans son jardin ses trois bars faire
parce que bon bah ça va et puis à ce
prix là je sais je sais ce que la
voiture c'est ce que coûte un thuya je
vous le dis je vous le dis je c'est ce
que coûtent étudiants